more than two million hindu pilgrims
gathered on the banks of the ganges
river before immersing themselves in the
water on monday
the three-month kum mela festival began
in uttarakhand state in january
it's going ahead this year despite india
seeing a recorded number of
coven 19 cases and deaths police say
they are unable to enforce restrictions
because of the sheer size of the crowds
if we try to enforce social distancing
an accident or stampede-like situation
can occur
so we're trying to avoid that we are not
able to implement social distancing at
the banks despite
wanting to do so but elsewhere in the
country restrictions such as night
curfews and weekend lockdowns are being
imposed
the number of cases in india has risen
from an average of around
10 000 a day in early february to 130
000 in the past week
prime minister narendra modi and health
officials say the rise is because of a
severe decline in appropriate actions
like wearing masks and social distancing
but despite that
modi and many other politicians have
been holding large rallies in the five
states where regional elections are
underway
the leaders are holding public rallies
to garner support
amit shah and narendra modi are holding
rallies at different places
but no one's paying attention to the
spread of coronavirus
and the deaths caused by it
medical experts say such gatherings
should not be allowed to take place
we are in a bad shape secondly people
talk about maharashtra state or mumbai
city where i am sitting today
but other states in the country they are
not equally bad they are extremely bad
because maharashtra in last one month
has jumped four times up
but there are states like uttar pradesh
or vr
they jump by 120 five times in one month
as cases rise rapidly many states have
also complained of vaccine shortages
which the government denies the indian
government is running behind schedule to
vaccinate 300 million people
in the first half of this year with the
country clearly in the throes of a
second wave of the corvona virus
its drugs regulatory body is meeting on
monday to consider emergency use
approval
of the russian-made sputnik vaccine
elizabeth paranam al jazeera new delhi